نائبه مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه للشرق
الاوسط دانا سترول دول المنطقه الى ممارسه
مزيد من الضغوط على ايران لتغيير سلوكها
وحضرت في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره من مخاطر
التعاون العسكري المتزايد بين ايران
وروسيا على منطقه الشرق الاوسط مضيفه ان
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه سيبحث غدا الاحد
خلال جولته في المنطقه خطوات لخفض التصعيد
في الضفه الغربيه
التي يبلغ عمرها عقودا من الزمن مع هذه
الدول وكذلك لسبل التعاون والتشاور
لمواجهه التهديدات في المنطقه وعلى مستوى
العالم وعلى راسها طبعا ايران وانشطاتها
المزعزعه للاستقرار في عموم المنطقه
والتهديد العالمي الحالي الذي تمثله بسبب
تعميقها التعاون مع روسيا اولويه اخرى
بطبيعه الحال هي التوترات المتصاعده في
الضفه الغربيه وكيف يمكن ان نتعاون لخفض
التصعيد
وخلت نائبه مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
للشرق الاوسط دانسترول في مقابلات خاصه مع
الجزيره ايضا ان ايران ستتصدر مباحثات
وزير الدفاع الامريكي خلال جولته الى
الشرق الاوسط التي ستبدا غدا الاحد
سيتشاور الوزير طبعا مع النثرائنا
الاسرائيلي حول تهديدات ايران ليس فقط
خطواتها النوويه الخطيره والتقدم في
برنامجها النووي وانما ايضا حول جميع
الانشطه الاخرى المزعزعه للاستقرار التي
تثير قلقا عميقا لدى جميع شركائنا في
الشرق الاوسط سواء عدوانيه ايران في البحر
ورعايتها وتمويدها وتسليحها وتجهيزها
لمجموعات غير تابعه للدول ولبكلاء عنيفين
وتهديداتها السيبرانيه والجويه من خلال
ترسانتها من الصواريخ الباليستيه
ومسيراتها الانتحاريه
وشددت استرول التي ترافق وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه خلال جولته على ان الدبلوماسيه
تظل الخيار المفضل للولايات المتحده
للتعامل مع برنامج ايران النووي الذي
وصفته بالخطير والفتاه الى ان دور
البنتاغون هو توفير خيارات عسكريه في حال
طلبها الرئيس
ين من المهم ان تدرك شعوب المنطقه
واسرائيل ان الدبلوماسيه هي الوسيله
الافضل للولايات المتحده للتعامل مع
برنامج ايران النووي لكن وظيفه وزاره
الدفاع ودور وزير الدفاع هما توفير خيارات
عسكريه موثوقه في حال طلبها الرئيس مره
اخرى اود ان اكون شديده الوضوح القوه
العسكريه هي خيارنا الاخير وليست على راس
خياراتنا المفضله